the Joe Rogan experience did you see
Francis in Ghana knockout Junior dos
Santos
yeah I didn't think it was a real
knockout he just blushed him look at him
he hit him and he went down and held his
head let him fight it out listen that
fight was over yeah listen to me that
fight was over yeah it doesn't matter
the scary thing is he just clipped he
clipped him he clipped him rocked him
put him down pounded on his head and
junior just couldn't he move he just
laid there and take it and they stopped
it quick there was a hundred percent
legitimate hundred percent legit I saw
between you and I that this would go a
little long I thought that he was a
seasoned veteran I thought that he would
go at least take him to the third round
and try to no you know nullify his power
by the third round you can't keep
throwing those [ __ ] hey make this I
thought he was gonna wrestle him it was
not what I anticipated it was not the
gameplan
I thought I got off stage and they were
starting his I gotta is that walked into
the green room [ __ ] didn't they were
gone and I was so [ __ ] happy I'm like
let me watch this I go I think June he
has a shot Ian as I thought that he was
already on the floor holding this
[ __ ] boy junior had a good start
where he was kicking the leg especially
the the lower part of the leg you could
really write someone up with yeah he
knocked him off balance and that can
really [ __ ] you up man like really mess
up your movement and if that was the
case if we was able to mess up his move
and get him to miss a little bit you
know may get him so that he was having a
hard time moving correctly and keep
chewing on that leg then maybe there
would be openings for him to to jump in
with some punches the problem is when
they're both on the outside francis is
bigger and the consequences are way more
grave and francis clips you it's 99 i
don't care who you are
he's so confident in it - he moves
forward and he's gonna throw everything
full-speed the first round with him is
extremely dangerous because he's just
trying to take you the [ __ ] out it takes
a guy like steep a steep a Miocic saw
what he was doing and what he did was
just ride with it just moved away from
him kept his hands up when francis was
coming after me use good defense and he
kept moving
and kept picking away at him picking
away out picking away at I'm taking his
shots when they were there and then
started wearing Francis down taking him
down beating them up and then just
dominated I'm clear-cut unanimous
decision for five rounds it takes a guy
like that a guy like Steve a that has
the mental fortitude to stick to a
gameplan not panic in the firefight
because that's what happens with in
Ghana you like Jesus Christ I'm gonna
see lights any second now
I'm gonna see a big flash and I'm gonna
be out cold any second now it's coming
and you see the reaction they have to
them it's they fight different they
fight different with him than they do
with anybody else because the
consequences are so grave you watch the
way he knocked out Alistair over him the
consequences are so grave so everyone's
scared no matter it's normal everyone's
scared to fight you know there's at
least there's gonna be some anxiety or
fear or you're gonna your heart rates
gonna get checked your dren tones gonna
be pumping but it's even more so if the
consequences are more grave right look
if you're gonna [ __ ] take a
skateboard down a small hill you're not
freaking out right but if you take it a
skateboard down like 4 Mile Canyon what
does that for my own Boulder what is
that one of those crazy roads that goes
sunshine Canyon right if you're taking a
skateboard down that going 50 miles an
hour you're gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ]
pants you're gonna try to land this
thing right try to figure out how not to
die here because the consequences are so
much graver you're gonna be more jacked
and that's what happens to these guys
and they fight Francis the consequences
are so grave they make mistakes and then
with jr. he reached for an overhand
right he just really really extended
himself you can't do that with Francis
but the scary thing is this true with
crow class says everybody has a game
plan and they get punched in the face
that's my advice in my times Isis yeah I
think it was it some guy oh that you
know you once you get that first point
to fight how I only saw two fights the
funniest one was the first one against
the kid from Dallas props to him he went
up against like a lieutenant the KKK the
guy drew blue on his face at the way and
they almost got into a little scuffle in
the way and then he had no [ __ ] love
and his face he didn't smile one time he
was definitely a member of the KKK and
this little black dude from Dallas came
in and he did a spinning back kick in
that dude it was all over he him no he
talking first fight on the Conn the main
card which [ __ ] defeated from he's
not from the displacer is yeah no I
didn't see first fight on the card
he's eight no no how did our strong
really good he still has two he's gonna
grow a little bit he's ever get knocked
out once before he really makes that big
jump but once he gets it the guy kept
doing spinning back kicks on him in the
second one he was right this bag this
guy just hates black people who the guns
right no that's Paul Craig yeah yeah
Paul Craig is great no he's probably
great it's a [ __ ] joke but did you
see what a meal first he went in with a
tough face you know I [ __ ] the guy
from he went in there like [ __ ]
Braveheart he's a tough guy Paul Craig
is good wait till you see the [ __ ]
fight I'll see it no he was great he
just tweeted anything I waited for the
second one and when the foot land and he
was right behind them not being no more
time clutch hoof I turned around they
hit him with a [ __ ] drop and right
hand you could see his feet just going
you know when you come yeah are you
feeling just playing the same thing it
was like he came he just what Jamie's
got it oh gee yeah it was ba what that's
the first one so he so right away he
timed it but that the back laugh Allah
pinga ba ba that's it little man look at
us the last one yeah while the guy
remembers and look at free boom boom ba
Bay goes boom boom there you go he's
probably right now reading [ __ ]
Malcolm X's - yeah I wonder why people
want to spin that much you know those
like that I hate all that [ __ ] spending
punches why you giving you back to a
killer I never understood it well that's
not what I'm saying I'm saying if you're
not that good at it
he doesn't have like a really fast you
can imagine Barbosa okay
Edson Barboza wheel kicks people and
puts them on Pluto he spinning back
kicks you to the body
you mean he's his kicks his spinning
kicks are [ __ ] insane but these guys
are not that good like
what I'm saying is like Paul Craig
that's not a specialty he's more of a
grappler but I mean he can strike
obviously it's a good striker but I
wouldn't think that he would want to
throw spin kicks this he's not like a
Taekwondo guy I don't if you don't do
Taekwondo for ten years why you spinning
kicking Lee you're seeing it's an
athletic yeah guy you know all those
that I hate when they even that reverse
punch when I keep is doing and doing I'm
like you know what choke him bust him in
the [ __ ] it see when you're talking
about like Edison Barboza though lands
it on Dan hangman you kept [ __ ]
kicking his body those spinning
back-kick just [ __ ] in so you gotta
commit to that's really magic speaking
about commitment
[Applause]